good afternoon first i want to thank you
all for coming out my name is
richard meyers i'm the lieutenant of the
homicide sex crimes bureau
and i'm over the sex crime section the
reason i'm here today is to provide you
an update from a sexual assault
that occurred on march 8 2021
in the 2200 block of north torrey pines
after a week-long investigation i'm
happy to inform the public that we've
made an arrest
in that case and we've knocked on over a
thousand doors during the course of this
investigation that took a week
collaborative effort from many members
of the las vegas metropolitan police
department
and many members of the community is
what led to the arrest of mr laprezi
jones
who you see over my left shoulder here
mr jones is currently being held
at the clark county detention center on
five felony counts
to include sexual assault and battery
with intent to commit sexual assault
i want to tell you a little background
about this case
stranger sexual assaults are the most
painstaking investigations for the
police department
because it's just that it's a stranger
and we have to figure out who that
stranger is that's preying on the
citizens of our community
and in this case a young lady was out
walking her dog in that neighborhood
and mr jones took advantage of that
young lady and attacked her when she
wasn't prepared to defend herself
mr jones attempted to strangle that
victim
and then he proceeded to sexually
assault the victim
again after a week-long exhaustive
investigation from the men and women
in the sex crimes bureau and the
officers at northwest area command
the evidence in the case led us to mr
jones
and he was arrested last night so he
could be held accountable for
the crimes that he committed on the
victim in this investigation
and with that i'll take a couple of
questions the victim is doing
okay sadly with sex crimes victims in
our cases will be victimized their
entire life they live the trauma of this
event
throughout the entire day of their life
while they're trying to heal through
this
at this point all the charges are for
that incident mr jones has had some
limited contact with the police
department
and so what we're asking is the public
to take a look at this man
and let us know by contacting crime
stoppers
if they've been the victim or if they
know somebody who's been the victim of a
crime that mr jones has committed
she was able to call 9-1-1
so the victim was in a fight for her
life and eventually 9-1-1 was called
okay again it's
at this point we have no cases that
we're tying mr jones to
there's an ongoing investigation
regarding him and we're asking the
public to come forward if they have any
information
if they are understand that he may be
involved in any criminal activity
yes as i stated sir it was a stranger
sexual assault and we take all crimes
very seriously but when we have a
stranger preying on the citizens of our
community
we take that to the top level and we run
a major case out of that
and we bring all of the resources of our
police departments and sometimes some of
our partners within the county
or the state to come forward and assist
us in that investigation
identifying him the the public did play
a part in this investigation
so we opened up a leads tips line and we
also received tips from crime stoppers
at this time because we're still
continuing to receive tips on this case
none of the tips that we received led to
the suspect's arrest
but we appreciate the public being
willing to come forward and to assist us
with these investigations
they play a pivotal part in this
investigation and the last thing that
i'll leave you with is we have a program
here at the lvmpd called
vegas safe cams if you go onto our
website
vegas safecam gives you the ability to
log your address and where your cameras
are located on your address
again because of this exhaustive search
knocking
approximately a thousand doors we have
hours and hours of video feed that had
we been able to go to that website
and know that the person at this
specific address had cameras
we could have gone to them quickly on in
the investigation and potentially
gained an investigative lead
so mr jones was arrested in the area of
vegas and rainbow
okay thank you have a good day